my friend is back
back here on the rich eisen show on the
mercedes-benz van phone line uh getting
set to join the nfl network first night
coverage of the draft for a tenth
consecutive year
the head coach of stanford football
david shaw back here on the program how
you doing coach
i'm doing great rich how are you are you
locked in on the tiger coverage is that
what's going on right now the good
stanford man that you are
probably me and most of america at least
have it on some device right now right
uh yeah absolutely absolutely he looks
amazing now do you have any contact with
him at all does he have any contact with
stanford uh football program in any way
shape or form whatsoever yeah coach we
we we touch base a few times a year
um
he came to visit us actually because we
played central florida a couple years
ago right not too far away from his home
and
came and gave a great speech to the guy
and brought a green jacket and
really uh really inspired a lot of our
guys which was awesome what do you mean
he brought he brought a jacket with him
is that what you're saying really he he
brought a green jacket uh to show the
guys and it was kind of going to be a
little bit of a surprise and
he was talking about playing at a high
level and playing for high stakes and
he uh had the head in the back gave a
great speech to the guy and he pulled
out a lot of oohs and awesome he
actually let me put it on my
on my back i i i
my skin was like it's just shivering
yeah this come on probably yeah yeah top
ten top ten non-football uh athletic
moments in my life no i don't but i mean
this is this is you don't even you're a
humble man but you should they just take
the humble out just brag just say it
with your chest especially since i don't
know how to fit it fit it fit like a
glove right that you and tiger have the
same have the same uh dimensions right
coach yeah uh you know lengthwise is
really close
um
i'm a little sicker in some areas than
he is and he's a little bigger in some
areas than i am what about the shoulders
come on it's gotta fit the whole thing
this is fast uh the shoulders are close
but he's he's done a lot more a lot more
weight room work than i have over the
last 10 years i'm wondering how many
people have actually been able to say
that they have worn a tiger woods one
and also brought to the occasion by
tiger woods tiger woods masters
championship jacket i can't imagine
that's a large number of people
surreal absolutely surreal
wow i love it so uh i'm assuming one of
the devices that you might be watching
tiger on right now is not your ipad
because i know that you have that out in
front of you for the nfl network draft
coverage all the time and that's on on
on to which you put all your information
i know absolutely absolutely i'm i'm
about 90 done with my preparation
already are you all right i love it oh i
only have to do the first round so i
have to do as many as everybody else
correct well you only do the cream of
the crop i mean you're stanford that's
you know only only certain people get on
your radar screen in real life david
shaw so i understand
so let's jump into it who who's jumped
off a film to you i mean and i know that
there you know kayvon thibodeau for
instance is somebody with clearly you
are very familiar with his work but who
has jumped off the film to you where you
were like okay didn't see that before or
this means something to move up a draft
board who's that guy so far david shaw
forgot i love evan neal
i really do to be that big
that long that smooth
um you know reminds me a lot of the
greats that play tackle in the nfl where
it it looks easy
just looks easy the way he can change
direction and deal with the secondary
pass rush and physical enough and
running game to move people
um that's he's he's he was really fun to
watch and besides that i mean obviously
um aidan hutchins but actually both guys
at michigan i appreciate how hard they
play
snap after snap after snap
variety of pass rush moves because your
your your first move is not always going
to be the one that wins but you see a
lot they can do a lot of different
things so
um those those three guys really got me
excited how about that okay and so um
your thoughts on the quarterback class i
know we've kind of kicked the tires on
that last time you were on about a month
ago but now that you are definitely part
of the nfl network coverage um i
couldn't be more excited about it what
what do you make of this quarterback
draft class david shaw
i think kenny pickett is ready to play
um i think he's
if you don't think he's spectacular
that's fine
but the guy's a really good quarterback
hand size doesn't bother me because he
throws the ball accurately
accurate good athlete tough kid smart
kid
the rest of the class to me is like
flares of ice cream you know what what
are you looking for what fits you
there's some guys with high ceilings
um like malik willis
desmond ritter that maybe aren't 100
ready to jump into an nfl team and play
but there's some height there's there's
a height up there uh athletically and
ability wise that you can see some
things that they may be able to do in
the nfl
i like matt corral last time we talked
uh i still really do he's got some
athleticism he plays with a fire he
plays with energy he can generate power
from different body positions which
you're going to have to in the nfl
and i like sam howell as well but for a
lot of those guys outside of kenny it's
now what are you looking for and what
fits your system so let's just jump into
the the crux of it what we're going to
be talking about is we're apparently
going to be in front of the bellagio
fountains on uh three weeks from tonight
david shaw um like you know like we're
in ocean's 11 together so um
one of my favorite movies by the by the
way um yes absolutely
i don't know if you're aware uh but we
are we are gonna we are breaking in uh
to the casino that night as well um so
just as long as i'm not the one that
goes in the thing that that he has to
come out of yes uh
yeah as long as i'm not that guy i'm
always yes you're not the grease man
don't worry i'll be the grease man so um
but uh when it all comes down to it it's
gonna be
panthers on the clock sixth overall
unless somebody's already traded up into
the fifth spot the giants are rumored to
say come come get this pick if you want
pick it um
do
let's just say pickets chosen by the
panthers six overall they don't have
another choice till the fourth round
what would you say like let's like i
guess rehearse would you say that this
is the proper maneuver for a panthers
team that already has sam donald sitting
there what do you think
uh
it would just say a lot about how they
feel about sam daryl obviously um
sam you have talked about sam for
multiple years now yes
when sam has time and sam has receivers
he is accurate he's athletic
he's got good size he's a tough son of a
gun he's taken a lot of hits over the
last few years always bounces back he's
never shied away
so organizationally they would just be
saying hey we're ready to move on and
take kenny and i think either path to me
makes a lot of sense because there's a
lot of things around that position first
of all you give whoever's playing
quarterback a healthy christian
mccaffrey which christian came to visit
us last week and he feels great you give
him a healthy christian mccaffrey maybe
get one more weapon you've already got a
couple of really good receivers and
maybe get a tight end
a little more athletic tied in and now
you've got a quarterback with some guys
around them that can make some things
happen so
kenny would be a great pick in my
opinion i think he's the most ready to
play
um he's tough he's smart he's accurate
he plays a
a little spunk a little fire um i think
that would be a good fit all right i'll
bite a little bit more he said you saw
mccaffrey he looks great i mean what
give me a little bit more on that
coach
uh
uh nfl comeback player of the year is
that too early
do we have to wait um we have to wait to
watch him uh work out
uh
but hey kirsten spent some time here
back at stanford um good talk with our
guys he and i sat down and talked for a
little bit he just he looks great he's
got that fire in his eye
and
just like all the greats
you give him something to battle
right he's coming off of an injury
people are now talking about is he going
to get traded what's all this stuff
and he's got that fire right now and he
is he is ready
um that's all i can say i know he is
ready and excited to start the off
season no i know and the question about
him david um is are are we seeing just a
a case of just terrible luck just awful
luck for the panthers for him for
football fans because of how dynamic he
is obviously there's the fantasy aspect
that you know in real life doesn't
matter but you know are we just seeing
somebody who's terribly unlucky or the
manifestation of the question marks that
surrounded him when he was drafted out
of your program that when it all comes
down to it the grind of an nfl season
will grind him down
you know
my opinion right now which i'm not going
to pretend that i'm not biased right uh
is is that it's been bad luck
you really watch christian mccaffrey
play
he doesn't get hit squarely very often
a lot of glancing blows so it's not like
he's been beaten up
he had an ankle that he tried to play
through that he couldn't play through
that happens a lot of different
positions so i don't see a running back
that's taken a lot of pounding that you
say man he's not going to be able to
hold up
um this guy's already broken multiple
nfl records
um he's had a couple of instances of of
just being a football player and getting
dinged up
but he is
quick still quick explosive athletic
it's not like one of those running backs
where he's lost a step and you don't
think he can do what he used to do
um the cat is still young and he's ready
to explode on the scene stanford
football head coach
david shaw he's going to be on the nfl
network thursday night drafts at three
weeks from tonight for the first round
of the nfl draft for a tenth straight
season right here on the rich eisen show
uh you mentioned different flavors right
for quarterbacks for what flavors team
teams like uh
give me give me the uh the wide receiver
class and who's your flavor who do you
think is the the class here that might
be top ten
um and and then a nice little steal
later on in the first round of a draft
where you know the packers and chiefs
who just lost the trade away devonte
adams and tyrek hill uh are sitting
there what do you got for me on that
front
well as much as it pains me to say
anything positive about somebody from
usc i do like drake london
um pig athletic and
his his ceiling we don't really know
what it is because he's really just
getting into his own as a football
player this guy was a basketball player
that's picked up football that's really
worked at it
for a big guy he's got great agility
he's got a ridiculous catch radius
hand-eye coordination
physical hard to tackle after the catch
but i go back and forth between he and
james
jameson williams
i love the speed and athleticism of
jameson
the way he can just i mean four or five
strides
he's already eaten up the cushion of
defensive backs he gets down the field
in a hurry he can stop and start
some health concerns but
the film tells me that that these two
guys
are the class of the group but i do like
garrett wilson wilson also from ohio
state
that guy that can be in the slot he can
be outside
he can be your fly sweep guy your
reverse guy your receiver screaming guy
your run after catch guy there are a lot
of different things that he can do and i
love versatility at the receiver
position so uh let's uh assume those
three guys will not be available when
the packers and chiefs pick who do you
like
down on that end of things
yeah
after those three guys for me
then it's what are you looking for right
chris a lava
downfield explosive receiver um
maybe not the over the middle guy maybe
not the short short area guy but can
really make some big plays down the
field
um i like trailing bursts from arkansas
bigger guy physical guy plays inside
um can be your possession plus not just
a possession receive because he can make
big plays and he's good after the catch
um and then jahan datsun from penn state
um good in the slot quick athletic
he's one of those guys if you're in a
lot of three to four receiver sets he
can really work the middle and get away
from guys and create some separations
for for your quarterback all right david
shaw you know um as much as i'm a team
player i mean you you've sat to my left
now for uh now coming up on a decade
you you know what it's all about for me
uh fourth overall selection uh new york
jets are on the clock
um what do you what what do you think
what's the best scenario for them with
overall what do you think i've got my
i've got my thoughts i've got some very
definite thoughts
uh but what do you think david shaw what
do you got
it's so tough when you have
no offense but you got a lot of areas
that you could really attack no offense
you can make a case for kyle hamilton
um
a serious difference maker at the safety
position
after losing jabal adams um kyle
hamilton
for me probably top three safeties that
i've seen in doing this thing in over a
decade
this guy i don't care what his 40 time
is
he comes out of the middle and makes
plays better than anybody um pretty much
anybody that i've seen so that's a
difference maker somebody back there
that can make a difference on that level
there are
defensive linemen and outside
linebackers aplenty
uh to take your pick to pick your poison
any of those guys
um i like jermaine johnson maybe a
little bit high from florida state but i
really like him
um so there are a lot of places in
particular on the defensive side that i
think are going to be good to choose
from
you didn't see my guy i'll tell you who
i i like david shaw i want sauce bring
me sauce bring me sauce forth overall
when you got stefan diggs signed forever
and a day in buffalo tyreek hill coming
to miami and then uh that that allows
the dolphins to tell the patriots of all
teams take another guy from us let the
devante parker do what welsh welker did
for you from us uh i want some kid who's
just saying i'll take him that's what i
want what do you think about that notion
i think that would be great and the
injury concerns about stingley you could
make a case for him as well but i i
think soft gardner is special
long fast athletic
um and a guy that you don't have to help
right you should be able to leave him
over there he can run with anybody he's
got size he's got ball skills um
apparently he just doesn't allow
touchdowns either which is uh
yes that's a good he reminds him well
he's got the body type of another
stanford man right um that in
richard sherman that's the guy that you
think of or unless i'm i'm
i'm doing too much of comp work i should
stay out of that lane what do you think
no no you're not that far away the
the 40 time a lot of times can be
mitigated by length
um and so the difference between four
six and four five or four five and four
four
can be mitigated if your your reach is
like seven feet tall
and this guy's got length he's got a
great feel for the game
he's physical
he's not going to back down for a single
human from a single human being on the
planet
um so i think that would be a great
pitch all right is this and again
you know what by the way gents what
you're getting is david shaw you know uh
had his finest right here but many times
david will then turn to me in a
commercial break saying yeah you're off
on that one you know
if this is a commercial break you
wouldn't be giving me that one right
this is that we're always on the same
page on kickers and partners
i appreciate that uh your spring games
coming up around the corner correct for
stanford football this saturday okay
what do you got for me you got any what
do what do you think about your team
give me give sanford football fans a
little morsel before i let you go david
shaw well
we are we are in an interesting spot
coming back off of a difficult year the
best thing for us that we had a lot of
guys that could have gone pro or could
have gone on the portal a lot of guys
came back
now we got a great mentality on our
football team and we may have a special
quarterback on our hands and tanner
mckee
um he's got size he's got athleticism
he's accurate got a strong arm
and we're going to have a pretty good
cast of characters around him so
things are looking up out here at
stanford all right coach david shaw
greatly appreciate it i will see you in
las vegas nevada i look forward to it
can't wait me too right back at you
that's coach david shaw one of my
favorite people right here on the rich
eisen show hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here